Let's go next to our caller from the 4 0 2
area code who's calling today from 4 0 2.
A. That may.
Yes, it is.
The mom, Ben, from coming from Georgia.
And that's my get your opinion on a couple
of thoughts I had.
One of them is, do you think Americans are
going to even have any tolerance or if it
matters, if they have any tolerance for these
large corporate bailouts that are coming?
Well, I think that there's a couple things.
Number one, if there are only corporate bailouts
and people don't start getting sent checks,
I think that there is not going to be tolerance.
And I would not be shocked to see people moved
to.
I'm not even going to say the words because
I don't want it.
I do want to encourage any of this.
Yeah, yeah, I know.
It's but I wouldn't be shocked to see things
happen if people see bailouts for corporations
and they don't get cash.
Now, the thing is, there should be some provision,
as some have suggested, the bailouts can't
be used for stock buybacks and.
And bonuses.
A kid that can do that.
There's no way that's going to make it in
now.
But there's no way that that's going to.
I mean, and here's the thing.
Even if you put it in.
The thing about money.
Money is fungible, right?
If I give you if I give you right.
80 bucks and I say don't use this 50 bucks
to buy alcohol, you go and buy alcohol, you
say, no, no, no.
You're 50 bucks is in my pocket.
I took a different 50 bucks and bought alcohol.
What can we even say, you know?
Right.
I mean, a big problem that I think people
are really not at least not in the media.
It seems like I mean, maybe some of them are
on the left side.
But like even at these pressers that he keeps
holding when he talks about bailouts, there's
absolutely nothing mentioned about stock buybacks.
Right.
Mentioning things like arrest, record breaking
profits.
When 96 percent of it from this point, the
airlines has gone to these stock buybacks.
This is exactly why they're in this problem
in the first place.
It's corporate socialism and there's not even
any hesitation about it.
It's just, oh, take money, take money, take
money, do whatever you want.
And then, of course, you know, we can't afford
we're arguing about.
Are are people going to get eight hundred
or a thousand bucks?
It's comes complete.
This is expose the Carone.
Right.
And they were certain.
Yeah.
I was going to say it's tragic in and of itself
because of the human risk.
But it's exposing the fragility of our economy,
the incredible hypocrisy of the people that
are manipulating the economy.
It's it's incredible what's going on.
Well, that's part of the crazy part is.
I know a guy from Not Real Arkansas.
He's a former transpark marketsite.
And one of the things he mentioned is that
the bailouts are going to you know, we're
going to need to bail out the airline industry.
And my jerk reaction was, you know, f um,
let him let him whatever.
But obviously, that's not really an option.
And it's almost boiling down to like when
people are talking about this.
We're not talking about some of the real issues
of becoming of like, oh, we need to do this
for the children type of thing where it's
like you can't question what is being done,
why we're even in this place right where we
are in the first place, or how we can work
to prevent this future.
It's just really goddamit, period.
Well, you know, one of the things, Ben, is
that we talked about this at the micro.
When there are vulnerable people, the grifters
show up.
So, for example, the people watching the Christian
TV are getting silver solutions sold to them
as a virus cure and all of this different
stuff at the macro economic level.
Any time that you have chaos like this, it's
an opportunity for corporate grifters and
influence peddlers and others.
A ton of money is going to be made on this.
People have been making money shorting the
stock market and there's going to be plenty
of money to pull out of this for people who
are ready and willing to do it.
And many of many people are.
All right, I would love to see if anybody
is able to look into people like Kushner and
et cetera, on how they are navigating the
current stock market, let alone I mean, you're
talking referring to like, you know, not smaller-scale,
but more religious type characters and then
corporate records.
I mean, when you've got we've got a grifter,
the goddamn leader of the country.
Right.
Just I don't I don't even know how to navigate
that going forward.
Obviously going to be sitting in it like a
day.
One scenario where we come back, nothing is
going to really be the same.
Is it just going to be a different kind of
normal for most Americans?
I it's hard to say.
Right.
We'll bleep that for the radio show.
But I mean, look at the language you vote.
I don't that Donald Trump and people around
him are using.
They're talking about patients as customers.
Trump's talking about exciting developments.
Trump, you know, he's taught all of this language
that the new he might have a new Corona virus
test out soon that will be more popular.
It's all like sales language.
It's sales and marketing language.
Yes.
It's bizarre.
So what's crazy?
And that's kind of my point.
And this is going to be a little bit of a
popular statement maybe.
But my position when I'm trying to assess
what to do in November, obviously I'm not
a huge fan of Biden.
He moved into left quite a bit, which is great.
Sure.
Whether he's gonna follow through on that.
Who knows?
I don't expect him to.
But at the same time, maybe we wouldn't.
Be in such a precarious position if we had
somebody that was at least mildly competent,
right.
Why are we surrounded a little with all the
right competent?
For me, it's not about vote blue, no matter
who.
That's an abstract theoretical debate.
For me, it's Biden versus Trump.
It's not about vote blue no matter who.
That's why I'm going to vote for Biden, because
I think we would be even in this current situation,
we would be better off.
Then I'm gonna let you go.
I really appreciate the phone call.
And I've got a bunch of people that that want
to get on.